[Musique]
nous appelons les Américains à faire
un vote moral dans un vote
euh priant et prophétique.
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux dire, si je m'endors avant,
je vérifierai juste le matin, certains
endroits disent  que Biden dirige,
certains endroits disent que Trump
dirige ainsi et je ne sais pas à qui faire confiance
à ce stade,
c'est comme des niveaux d'anxiété que je suis
anxieux depuis quatre ans ou plus
au lieu de rester à la maison à regarder
uniquement les informations que nous pensions  que nous passerions du
temps avec les gens que nous aimons
en attendant les résultats des élections
et en profitant de la compagnie de chacun
[Musique]
nous remettons tout entre de bonnes mains
quoi qu'il décide pour le pays,
ce sera le meilleur, nous sommes très
anxieux  à propos des résultats que nous
attendons toujours pour l'Arizona, le Michigan et quelques
autres États,
donc je vérifie mon téléphone toutes les cinq
minutes, j'ai hâte que ce soit fini
pour être honnête
[Musique]
je ne suis pas inquiet, je pense que l'Amérique  ça
avance
et notre génération et nos gens sont
plus conscients et voient plus de vérité
ce qui se passe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
détenu, il y
a de l'espoir en Amérique, la démocratie
va être restaurée
oh je peux à peine respirer  c'est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
je suis heureux de l'
élection de Joe Biden,
comment vous vous sentez qui est votre nouveau président,
cela a été quatre années d'enfer, quatre ans
à avoir
le sentiment que nous n'avons pas d'importance et maintenant nous
savons que les gens savent que nous comptons
toi